[Music]
BTS is everywhere and people can't get
enough of them please welcome after
finding success in South Korea they were
able to make a huge splash
internationally tickets for their global
concert tour sold out within hours of
being released they became the
first-ever kpop act to make a number one
album with 2018 s love yourself tear and
they're not stopping anytime soon their
newest album map of the soul persona is
already looking like it'll be a huge hit
and of course people camped outside for
days to see them perform live on
Saturday Night Live but BTS wasn't an
overnight sensation it took them years
of hard work to get to this level
BTS debuted in June 2013 and they
quickly gained a dedicated fanbase
thanks to social media they show a lot
of love and appreciation for their fans
who they even named army which means
adorable representatives for MC youth
and in 2017 BTS won the top social
artists billboard award breaking Justin
Bieber's 6-year winning streak and
making them the first kpop act to win a
Billboard Music Award unsurprisingly
they won again in 2018
[Applause]
VTS also became the first kpop band to
perform at the American Music Awards in
2017 gaining them even more fans
internationally but the fans don't just
love them for their mind-blowing
performances they love BTS for their
socially conscious music BTS writes
their own music which tackles complex
topics like bullying mental health and
societal pressures BTS stands for
bangtan sonyeondan or bulletproof Boy
Scouts in English
according to member judez hope the name
signifies the group's desire to block
out stereotypes criticisms and
expectations that are imposed on
adolescents essentially they're
bulletproof their work is also inspired
by literature art and even philosophy
the music video for blood sweat and
tears references and showcases a few
famous European paintings and their
newest album is based off the book
Jung's map of the soul which explores
the theories of Swiss psychiatrist Carl
Jung mostly fans can't get enough of the
chemistry among the members the band
consists of seven members RM Jin sugah
j-hope jimin v and jungkook since
becoming a global sensation they've
collaborated with many famous artists
including American DJ's Steve Aoki who
remixed Mike drop and collaborated on
the truth untold on the heels of the
remixes Aoki featured BTS members
jungkook and RM and wasted on me this is
the members first all english-language
song
BTS also released an alternative version
of their song Idol featuring Nicki Minaj
the music video received over 45 million
views in its first 24 hours on YouTube
breaking the venn record previously set
by Taylor Swift with look what you made
me do their newest album features even
more collaborations this time with Ed
Sheeran on a track called make it right
and Halsey on boy with love this
collaboration is already blowing up on
YouTube with yet another hit on their
hands the sky's the limit for BTS
[Music]
you
[Music]